el siguiente triángulo tiene un área de
75 unidades cuadradas encuentra el lado
faltante pausa en el vídeo y traten de
encontrar este lado que falta
vamos a resolverlo juntos nos dan el
área que es de 75 unidades cuadradas nos
dan este lado de aquí que es un 11 y nos
dan este lado de 10 que si rotamos este
triángulo veremos que es la altura vamos
a hacerlo
vamos a rotar este triángulo para que
vean mejor cómo podemos resolver esto lo
copiamos lo pegamos y lo rotamos y aquí
quizás puedan ver mejor que este lado
que queremos encontrar es la base de
este triángulo y también nos están dando
el área y sabemos cómo se relaciona la
base con el área sabemos que el área es
igual a un medio por la base por la
altura y aquí nos dicen que el área es
de 75 unidades cuadradas por lo que 75
es igual a un medio por la base y cuál
es la base pues es justamente el lado
que no conocemos está x así que es un
medio por x por la altura y cuál es la
altura pues justamente este 10 si x es
la base éste
va a ser la altura en este ángulo recto
de hecho este onceno nos sirve para nada
solo lo ponen para distraernos por lo
que esto va a ser nuestra altura 10 75
es igual a un medio por x por 10 podemos
reescribirlo como 75 igual a un medio
por 10 5 por x a que será igual x
podemos verlo como x por 5 es igual a 75
y pueden decir bueno 5 por 10 50 y
necesitamos otro 25 por lo que le
agregamos un 5 por lo que sería 5 por 15
o podemos ser más sistemáticos y dividir
ambos lados entre lo que está
multiplicando a la x que es 55 por equis
entre 5 nos va a quedar la equis sola
pero estas dos cosas no son iguales así
que tenemos que hacer lo mismo de este
otro lado de la igualdad dividimos ambos
lados entre 5 y 75 entre 5 nos da 15 lo
que nos da x igual a 15 y podemos
verificarlo si x es igual a 15
el área será la base por la altura por
un medio 15 por 10 por un medio es 15
por 5 lo que nos da 75 unidades
cuadradas